wir kommen zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt und der knüpft noch
mal an an den heutigen Vormittag hier im
Bundestag da gab es ja eine
Regierungserklärung von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz zu einem Jahr Zeiten werden
die in seiner Regierungserklärung hat
der Bundeskanzler noch mal deutsche
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
verteidigt und Forderung nach einen
schnellen Friedensverhandlungen einer
Absage erteilt mit der Waffe an der
Schläfe ließe sich nicht verhandeln so
hat der Bundeskanzler heute morgen
gesagt außer über die eigene
Unterwerfung und er sagte weiter es
könnte keinen Friedensschluss über die
Köpfe der Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
hinweggeben in diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
jetzt der auf Antrag der Linksfraktion
hier aufgesetzt wird fordert DIE LINKE
an sofortigen Waffenstillstand und eine
diplomatische Initiative für
anschließende friedensverhandlung das
spricht als erstes gregorie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen über ein Jahr
müssen wir nun den völkerrechtsmitteln
den Krieg der Russischen Föderation
gegen die Ukraine miterleben
bei dem völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg der
NATO gegen Serbien und bei der
völkerrechtswidrigen Lostrennung des
Kosovo habe ich in Gesprächen mit
damaligen Regierungsmitgliedern gewarnt
dass dies Schule machen können was
leider eingetreten ist ich weiß dass vor
diesem Krieg vom Westen vieles falsch
gemacht wurde und die Ukraine mit zwei
Verletzte das Gebiet wurde nicht autonom
innerhalb der Ukraine außerdem war das
damalige Verbot der russischen Sprache
ebenso falsch all dies rechtfertigt aber
niemals einen völkerrechtsverjährigen
Angriffskrieg
wir erleben Kriegsverbrecher
insbesondere von russischer Seite Folter
Tötung von Zivilisten
Vergewaltigung es muss ein
völkerrechtlicher Weg gefunden werden
Schuldige bei allen Kriegen zur
Verantwortung zu ziehen
unsere Solidarität gehört der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung
im Unterschied zu anderen hier war ich
nicht zu einer Stippvisite in der
Ukraine sondern zusammen mit Professor
Trabert dort mehrere Tage wir haben
medizinische Geräte und Spenden
übergeben der Bürgermeister eines
Vorortes von Kiew für die Zerstörungen
beseitigen und bat um einen kleinen Bus
ein Traktor und eine betonmaschine
Mischmaschine meine entsprechende Bitte
an dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck wurde
Geld verpennt per Panzer ja für eine
Betonmischmaschine nein mit Hilfe des
sächsischen
CDU-Ministerpräsidenten Kretschmann ist
es gelungen mit einer
Städtepartnerschaft die bitten zu
realisieren das Verhalten der
Bundesregierung finde ich in diskutabel
die Frage wie dieser Krieg das Grauen
beendet werden kann treibt unsere ganze
Bevölkerung um
es gibt in Kern zwei unterschiedliche
Antworten wenn wir eine tiefe Spaltung
unserer Gesellschaft verhindern wollen
sollten wir respektieren dass die einen
wie die anderen
Frieden zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine wollen
die einen glauben mittels
Waffenlieferungen das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine zu
stärken und einen gerechteren Frieden zu
erreichen wir die das anders sehen
dürfen sie nicht als Kriegstreiber oder
ähnliches sehen und beleidigen
diejenigen die wie wir
unverzüglich ein Waffenstillstand wollen
möchten das Töten verletzen die
Zerstörungen sofort beenden deshalb ist
es ebenso falsch uns als putinsknechte
zu bezahlen
wir haben inzwischen einstellungskrieg
der BND-Präsident wie es darauf hin dass
Russland noch bis zu einer Million
Soldaten rekrutieren können die Ukraine
hat eine solche weitgehende Möglichkeit
nicht Jürgen habermaß erklärte dass die
NATO bisher ihr Ziel nicht definiert
habe er schrieb weiter das ist ein
Unterschied gebe ob ein Land Siegen
müsse oder ob es nicht verlieren dürfe
interessant
mir wird entgegnet das Putin zu einem
Waffenstillstand nicht bereit sein was
halten sie von folgender Idee mit
Einverständnis der ukrainischen Führung
könnte die NATO doch erklären dass sie
jetzt keine einzige Waffe mehr an die
Ukraine lieferte wenn die russische
Führung einem Waffenstillstand zustimmte
das setzte sie beachtlich unter Druck
das Ergebnis dann von
Friedensverhandlungen muss eine auch vom
Besten gesicherte Ukraine sein wir
müssen einen Weg finden wie wir zu
Deeskalation Abrüstung
Interessenausgleich viel mehr Diplomatie
und strikter Wahrung des Völkerrechts
durch alle Seiten zurückkehren können
die Regierung muss aufhören wegen der
Kosten im Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg und
den Flüchtlingen Sozialleistungen in
Frage zu stellen eine solche Aufrechnung
für Nachteil gerade der ärmeren Teile
unserer Bevölkerung ist durch
zurechtfertigen die Inflation die
Teuerung der Lebensmittel liegen die
unerträglichen Preise für Heizung und
Strom müssen wirksam bekämpft werden
letztlich bin gleich fertig es gibt auch
die völkerrechtswidrigen Kriege des
nato-mitglieds Türkei gegen Syrien und
Irak speziell gegen die kodeln und
Kurden die uns alle im Kampf gegen den
islamischen Staat unterstützt hat es
gibt seit Jahren ein furchtbaren Krieg
im Jemen mit unvorstellbaren Leid
dahinter stehen der Iran und
Saudi-Arabien wenn wir glaubwürdig sein
wollen müssen wir diese kriegen
ebenfalls scharf verurteilen ich hoffe
dass unsere öffentlich-rechtlichen
Medien endlich einmal Bilder von diesen
Kriegen zeigen damit sich humane
solidarische Gefühle in unserer
Bevölkerung entwickeln können
das ist das Beste für die Ukraine mehr
Waffen zur Gegenwehr und die Fortführung
des Kriegs oder ein Stopp der
Waffenlieferung aus dem Westen und
Verhandlungen mit Russland für beide
Wege gab es beispielsweise am
vergangenen Wochenende Demonstration
eine große Demonstration am Samstag zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine am
Freitagabend und am Samstag die Gegner
weiterer Waffenlieferungen unter anderem
ja initiiert von der Linken Politikerin
Sarah Wagenknecht von der Linken Spitze
gab es davorwürfe Sahra Wagenknecht
Grenze sich nicht nach rechts ab also
die Debatte innerhalb der Linken wie man
sich positioniert ist durchaus teilweise
sehr scharf geführt in nächster Redner
ist für die SPD
und mehr noch der Unterschied zwischen
Wort und Tat zwischen der schlussversion
Ihres Antrags und im öffentlichen
Auftritt ist demutant nicht schwarz als
gerade zu erschrecken
seit über einem Jahr suchen wir nach
wegen ihrer endlich Frieden in Europa
kriegen können Leid und tot zerstören
russische kriegsverbrechende kokaine den
ungebrochen weiter trotzdem zwischen
100.000 Tote ist noch immer kein Ende in
Sicht das entsetzlich und jeder neue
kriegt hat gerade deshalb fehlt mir
wirklich jedes Verständnis mit welcher
Kälte ihre Fraktionskollegen waren nicht
im Fernsehen das unglaubliche Leitung
und Vergewaltigung durch russische
Soldaten kommentiert
die glatte politrhetorik zum Krieg vor
unserer Haustür und die pr-getriebene
Selbstverliebtheit der Demoleitung
beschädigen maximal die glaubwürdigung
von friedenspapellen hier im Bundestag
das ist keine linke Friedenspolitik
meine sehr verehrten Damen und
ihren Tag fordert Diplomatie statt
Panzer das ist mir wirklich nicht
unsympathisch auch gegen eine
verhandlungsinitiative zu Beendigung des
Krieges kann man wenig einwenden solange
Putins versucht die Grenzen mit Gewalt
zu verschieben nicht belohnt wird ich
freue mich über uns auch darüber wenn
Menschen für Frieden demonstrieren habe
da selbst auf genug getan halt auch
nichts von der pauschalen die Vermehrung
von Demonstranten intellektuellen und
Unterstützern diverse Aufrufe auch wenn
ich die Auffassung nicht Teile und
manche Formulierung überhaupt nicht
Teile was aber gar nicht geht ist hier
Anträge für Friedensverhandlungen zu
stellen und gleichzeitig gemeinsam mit
Rechtsextremisten auf die Straße zu
gehen ohne dass die Fraktionsführung
eindeutig distanziert ich habe bei der
Debatte zu dem scheinheiligen aktiv
friedensantrag hier betont dass sie den
rechten Knie und Frieden sondern immer
um die Unterstützung des russischen
Diktators geht meine lieben sie müssen
sich schon entscheiden wer sich nicht
klar von Rechtsextremisten an diese
mieten und reichsbürgern abgrenzt und
jede und ich meine wirklich jede Form
der Zusammenarbeit verweigert der steht
nicht glaube Frieden und er steht auch
nicht links
und die Erklärung von Sahra wagenknechts
Ehemann der nun wirklich kein
politikneuling ist man mache keine
Gesinnungsprüfung bei Demos ist eine
intellektuelle Beleidigung meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren mit Rechten
demokratiefeinen macht man niemals
nirgendwo aus keinem anders gemeinsame
Sache meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
und da muss man sich schon fragen warum
der Neonazi Björn höcke ihrer damalige
Fraktionsvorsitzende zum einen in seiner
afd-truppe auffordert was wollen sie
sich noch alles gefallen lassen wollen
sie warten bis eine Liste Wagenknecht
rechts auf Stimme angeht ich diskutiere
gerne mit Ihnen über progressive außen
Friedenspolitik die die europäische
friedensverordnung wieder herstellt wir
brauchen keine Konjunkturprogramme für
Rüstungsindustrie wir brauchen noch
keine Kriegswirtschaft da sind wir uns
einig was sie aber brauchen ist eine
moderne und gut ausgestattete
parlamentserfahrung Armee die fähig ist
ihre bündnisverpflicht und auch kam der
Landesverteidigung zu erfüllen deshalb
und nicht Ausrüstung aufrüstungsgründen
haben wir den Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr von 100 Milliarden Euro
zugestimmt wir werden ihrem Antrag nicht
zustimmen weil manches fehlt und anders
einfach falsch ist der Vorwürfe würden
ausschließlich auf militärische Mittel
setzen und die Fortsetzung des Krieges
stabilisieren mögen Sie bitte an die
richten die sich Nerven ständig so
äußern mit denen setze ich mich auch
auseinanderbringen für den Bundeskanzler
für die Bundesregierung für die
sozialdemokratische Bundestagsfraktion
geht das Gegenteil die Bürger und Bürger
können sich darauf verlassen wir
unterstützen die Ukraine über ihre
Selbstverteidigung politisch ökonomisch
humanitär und auch militärischer langer
es notwendig ist und wir werden mit
Deutschland und der NATO definitiv keine
Kriegsteilnehmer und wir handeln stets
gemeinsam mit unserem Verbündeten in
Washington und Paris wir unterstützen
jede seriöse diplomatische Anstrengung
für Frieden ihre Aufforderung an die
Bundesregierung Bedarf ist wirklich
nicht
zusammengefasst ihre Worte höre ich wohl
allein mir fehlt der Glaube dass die
gesamte Linke bereit ist diesen Krieg
als das zu beschreiben was er ist ein
illegaler verbrecherischer und
imperialistischer Raub zu großteils
gegen Ukraine lassen Sie das
anti-amerikanische Geraune das ist von
rechts genauso und sympathisch wie von
links es gibt genau einen der für den
Krieg Verantwortlichen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
bringen
ihre rechte Flanke lassen Sie uns gerne
weiter konstruktiv über modernen Dinge
Friedenspolitik streiten das ist aber
nicht wenn man auch von Täter
durcheinander bringt das ist nicht wenn
man Menschen verweigert sich zu werden
das ist schon gar nicht wenn man kein
Mitgefühl hat für die die dann auch dazu
leiden haben und das ist der Teil der
uns bewegen muss dafür zu sorgen dafür
zu sorgen dass wir dahin kommen und sie
wissen sehr genau dass sie mich mit den
kritisch auseinandersetzen
sozusagen
herstellen das geht aber nur wenn man
sich ehrlich macht wenn man nicht mit
zweier der Maßstäben lässt und schon
gleich gar nicht wenn man mit Demokratie
irgendwas zusammen machen
war das für die SPD und wenn wir in die
Reihen der Linken schauen da sitzen der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Bartsch und die
Parteichefin Janine Wissler Sahra
Wagenknecht die wahrscheinlich immer
wieder auch Gegenstand in dieser Debatte
sein wird mit ihrer Demonstration am
Samstag die ist nicht hier im Plenarsaal
zur Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers heute hat schon gezeigt
dass die Fraktion in der Mitte dieses
Hauses eng zusammenstehen in ihrer
Solidarität an der Seite des
ukrainischen Volkes und ich kenne mich
den Worten des Kollegen Stegner nur
anschließen und auch dem was der
Bundeskanzler man Fraktionsvorsitz heute
morgen gesagt haben das ist ein
verbrecherischer Krieg den Präsident
Putin
angezettelt hat den er allein zu
verantworten hat und Herr Kollege Gisi
was an ihrer Unterscheidung an und oder
an ihrem daneben stellen der zwei von
Ihnen definierten Gruppen hier in
Deutschland so falsch ist dass sie
nämlich so tun als sei das sozusagen
gleichberechtigt in seinem moralischen
Anspruch hier gibt es eine Seite die hat
angegriffen und hier gibt es eine andere
Seite und das ist die ukrainische Seite
und die hat jedes moralische übrigens
auch völkerrechtliche Argument sich zu
verteidigen und das ist die Seite an die
wir als Deutsche gehören und glaube es
ist von entscheidender Bedeutung
dass wir hier Unterschiede nicht
verwischen dass wir Verantwortlichkeiten
benennen und dass wir Maßstäbe einhalten
die wir dann in der Tat auch anderswo
auf der Welt anwenden und das was sie im
Ergebnis hier machen ist dass sie das
narrativ Putins bedienen und in der Tat
ist ja auffällig gewesen dass der
Beifall von der afd-fraktion für ihre
Rede mindestens genauso groß gewesen ist
wie der Beifall den sie aus den eigenen
Reihen bekommen haben darüber sollten
Sie nachdenken
darüber sollten Sie nachdenken wenn ich
glaube wir haben eine
gemeinsame wir haben eine gemeinsame
Verantwortung
hier die demokratische Mitte und
übrigens die parlamentarische Mitte und
den Parlamentarismus aufrecht zu
erhalten und ich will das jetzt an
dieser Stelle mal sagen die Art und
Weise wie die Kollegin Wagenknecht
dieses Parlament den sie angehört und
für die Zugehörigkeit ja Diäten bezieht
missachtet indem sie in keinem Ausschuss
Mitglied ist
Reihe Weise an Abstimmungen auch
namentlichen Abstimmung nicht teilnehmen
und auch heute an diesem Parlament Tag
es nicht für nötig hält auch nur eine
Sekunde in diesem Haus zu verbringen ist
eine Missachtung des Parlamentarismus
ist eine Missachtung des
Parlamentarismus den nicht akzeptabel
ist liebe Kollegen
und
da hat ein kluger Journalist in den
letzten Tagen einen Kommentar
geschrieben der deutlich gemacht hat
dass das am Kern
demokratiefeindlichkeit ist was Frau
Wagenknecht zum Ausdruck bringt und die
schließe mich dem an
weil völlig abgesehen von den
antisemitischen Einschränkungen die
außerordentlich unappetitlich sind die
das zusätzlich hat und deswegen ich bin
mache mich nicht an der Kollege
stinkender sozusagen hier zu formulieren
was gute linke Politik ist da wäre ich
mit Sicherheit der falsche
an der Stelle wäre vielleicht sogar der
Kollege Stegner der richtige aber ich
muss schon sagen wir müssen und ich
glaube wir haben eine gemeinsame
Verantwortung in diesem Hause darauf
aufmerksam zu sein das nicht Dinge
wieder passieren die in diesem Land zu
unseligen Zeiten die Grundlage dafür
gelegt haben dass Nationalsozialisten in
diesem Land die Macht übernommen haben
und das heißt dass wir den ich würde
gerne fortführen frau Präsidentin das
heißt dass wir den
Herrn
bei allen parteipolitischen Streit was
sachlicher Auseinandersetzung aber was
auch Achtung von Institutionen was
Achtung von grundlegenden Regeln unseres
demokratischen Gemeinwesens angeht dass
wir das gemeinsam einhalten und das
stelle ich fest hier verwischen die
Grenzen und dabei ist schon weniger noch
die Gefahr dass hier ein
Hufeisen sich sondern insgesamt
dass hier eine Gruppe von Politikern von
ganz links und von ganz rechts Einfluss
gewinnt auf eine leidersteigende Zahl
von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in unserem
Land die von unserem demokratischen
Gemeinwesen sich wegbewegen und dem
müssen wir uns alle entschlossen
entgegenstellen entgegenstellen
[Applaus]
wollen und habe ja noch ein paar
Präsidentin lassen wollen
abschließend einfach folgendes sagen es
kommt ja in dem Aufruf auch zum Ausdruck
da wird er die Behauptung aufgestellt
Russland sei atomar bewacht und man
könnte eigentlich deswegen nicht
verantwortungsvoll gewinnen oder
weiterführen erstens ist das falsch weil
die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und
vietnamen und die frühere so wird Union
in Afghanistan eine andere Erfahrung
gemacht haben aber meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das perverse an dieser
Überlegung ist und ich finde das dürfen
wir nicht vergessen auch für die Zukunft
die Ukraine
die eigenen Atomwaffen dem Land dass sie
jetzt überfällt in dem Vertrauen in die
Hand gegeben dass die Souveränität
gewahrt wird und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn wir nicht wollen
dass der Iran und das
Nordkorea daraus die falschen Schlüsse
ziehen dann müssen wir gerade gegenüber
Russland an der Stelle eine besondere
Härte und nicht gerade eine besondere
Weichheit
zum Ausdruck bringen denn die Verletzung
dieser besonderen souveränitätsgarantie
die die Ukraine empfangen hat um den
Preis der Abgabe von Atomwaffen darf
nicht dazu führen dass die Souveränität
gerade verletzt wird sondern dass sie
extra beschützt wird und deswegen
verpflichtet uns das in besonderem Maße
der Ukraine zur Seite zu stehen vielen
Dank
ja während der rede hier von Johann war
voll für die Union gab es auch
verschiedenste Anzeichen Antrag auf
Zwischenfragen jetzt hör mal die
Bundestagspräsidentin
habe selber dran Herrn Vahle lasse ich
zu und weise Sie darauf hin dass
Kurzintervention eine besondere
Begrenzung unterliegen was die Zeit des
zeitlicher Ausmaß angeht mit Robert
Vahle als fraktionsloser darf jetzt also
eine Kurzintervention machen Präsidentin
nur ganz kurz erstens die Kritik was die
Arbeit im Parlament anbelangt dass man
hier nicht kommt
das ist das was ich auch für richtig
finde wenn ich in der Öffentlichkeit für
die Friedenspolitik eintrete dann muss
ich auch den Respekt vor dem Parlament
mitbringen hier zu erscheinen und mit zu
diskutieren das teile ich aber ich hätte
gerne gefragt den Kollegen der gerade
gesprochen hat ob er das gut findet wenn
man den Respekt vor dem Parlament hat
wie ist der lensky mit seiner Opposition
in der Ukraine
umgegangen ist alle verboten hat
zum Teil hat verfolgen lassen und sogar
die Presse in der Ukraine vollständig
gleichgeschaltet ist das hat doch mit
demokratischen Parlamentarismus
0,nichts zu tun danke
möchten sie darauf antworten bitte sehr
Meldung nicht allzu viel Aufmerksamkeit
zukommen lassen wollen aber eines
festhalten das was sie hier zur Politik
in der Ukraine und zur Politik des
ukrainischen Präsidenten gesagt haben
ist schlichtweg falsch
[Applaus]
jetzt wieder regulär auf der Rednerliste
Jürgen Trittin für die Grünen als
Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss meine
Damen und Herren das war jetzt der
Versuch der Linkspartei hier im Hause
Einigkeit zu demonstrieren dazu schicken
sie dich lieber Gregor hier hin weil
alle über dich positiv annehmen du bist
ein verständlich diskutierender
reflektierter Mensch
und das was du ja aber abgeliefert hast
war an Verlogenheit nicht zu überbieten
ich will mal ganz deutlich sagen sich
hier hinzustellen und zu sagen die
Bundesregierung gebe Geld für Panzer
aber habe nicht mal Geld für einen
kleinen Trecker in der Ukraine zu helfen
das kann man schon nicht mal mehr als
Unwahrheit bezeichnen
ich will mal darauf hinweisen dass diese
Bundesregierung über das Ministerium für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit 650 Milli
Millionen in die Ukraine gegeben hat
dass sie über das BMI 500 Millionen in
die Ukraine gibt dass sie über das AA
fast 800 Millionen unter anderem
700.000 Stromgeneratoren geliefert hat
und dass diese Bundesregierung über das
Finanzministerium
6,24 Milliarden ausgegeben hat rein
Zivil zum großen teilbudget-hilfe für
die Ukraine die Behauptung wir würden
hier niemanden Zivil unterstützen
ist eine Lüge
und dann wird der Versuch sozusagen die
eigene Spaltung die die Linkspartei über
die krisenkrieg hat zu bemänteln auf der
einen Seite Sahra Wagenknecht mit
Porsche Klaus mit
Gregor Gysi der auch aufgerufen hat
dorthin zu gehen er ist nicht neutral
und Seven daddelem und auf der anderen
Seite Mitglieder Mitglieder wie Klaus
Lederer oder Bodo Ramelow und dazwischen
steht die Parteiführung von Janine
Wissler und weiß nicht was passiert der
Kollege möchten Sie eine Zwischenfrage
von Herrn wie sie zulassen nein ich
mache jetzt essen
der Abgeordnete Gregor Gysi hat die
Möglichkeit zu einer Zwischenfrage an
den Abgeordneten Jürgen bitte schön
Herr Kollege Trittin abgesehen davon
dass auch grün und Sozialdemokraten das
Manifest und dann zeichnet haben möchte
ich Sie folgendes Fragen ich habe einen
Brief der parlamentarischen
Staatssekretärin aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium erhalten wo
drinsteht dass für den Traktor den Bus
und den Beton Mischmaschine keine
Strukturen und kein Geld vorhanden ist
dann hat sich ein Journalist der
Süddeutschen Zeitung damit beschäftigt
hat recherchiert und wurde gesagt
eigentlich sei ja das
Entwicklungsministerium zuständig
daraufhin hat er gefragt warum haben Sie
denn diese nicht geantwortet er soll
sich
Entwicklungsministerium wenden dafür
haben wir gesagt weil wir uns erkundigt
haben die haben dafür auch kein Geld und
keine Strukturen es war nicht möglich
diesen Traktor diesen Bus und die Beton
Mischmaschine für den Vorort von KFZ zu
realisieren über den CDU
Ministerpräsidenten Sachsens ist es
gelungen deshalb war das keine Lüge
sondern absolut wahr und belegbar was
ich gesagt habe
lieber Kollege
easy
wenn man schon im Loch sitzt sollte man
vermeiden auch noch weiter was
zuzuschütten meine Aussage hat ganz
einfach gelautet wer hier den Eindruck
erweckt die Bundesregierung würde
ausschließlich Panzer liefern und mit
einem solchen Beispiel versucht zu
illustrieren das Deutschland keine
zivile Hilfe gibt der sagt bewusst die
Unwahrheit und ich fühle mich eines
hinzu ich hätte mega deswegen habe ich
mehr gefreut die wäre Zwischenmeldung
aber wie jemand mit einer aufrechten
linken Haltung zu einer Demo aufrufen
kann
wo auf zusätzlich ein Jürgen Elsässer
ankündigt dort mit nationalen fahren zu
demonstrieren ich finde lieber Kollege
Gregor Gysi sie haben den politischen
Kompass in dieser Situation vollständig
verloren
ich will an der Stelle
Bemerkung machen man muss ja auch nicht
die eigene Naivität irgendwie so
demonstrieren
haben Sie eigentlich nicht zur Kenntnis
genommen was Herr Peskow dass der
Sprecher des Kreml auf die Forderung der
Verbündeten Chinesen doch bitte ein
Waffenstillstand zu machen sagen das ist
derzeit gibt es dafür keine Grundlage
die Wahrheit ist es ist nicht die
Bundesregierung es ist nicht
Europa es ist nicht die Ukraine es ist
Russland das einen Waffenstillstand den
Sie hier verlangen nicht will und die
Frage muss man sich doch stellen wie
kommt man in einer solchen Situation zu
Verhandlung ich habe mir mal die Mühe
gemacht in der Geschichte ein Beispiel
zu suchen was vielleicht der Linken
hilft
wie ist es zugekommen das Lido und Henry
Kissinger
angefangen haben über Frieden zu reden
obwohl die USA Richard nichts mehr
versprochen hat Vietnam in die Steinzeit
zurückzukommen
dafür waren zwei Dinge von zentraler
Bedeutung das eine waren die
Waffenlieferung Chinas und der
Sowjetunion an den Viet kommen die
verhindert haben dass sie Vietnamesen
von der Übermacht der Amerikaner
überrannt wurden und das andere das war
der Aufstand einer ganzen Generation auf
diesem Globus gegen diesen Krieg der die
USA in eine politische Isolierung
geführt hat die ihn dazu gezwungen hat
sich auch Verhandlungen einzulassen und
genau das ist es was wir als
Bundesregierung mit diesem Krieg
versuchen wir wollen verhindern dass die
Ukraine überrannt wird dafür liefern wir
Waffen und wir setzen auf Diplomatie
diplomatie ist nicht schön dass wir mal
drüber gesprochen haben diplomatie ist
dafür zu sorgen dass in den Vereinten
Nationen 141 Staaten gemeinsam den
Rückzug Russlands aus der Ukraine
fordern Diplomatie
diplomatie ist es auch wenn wir dahin
gehen die Finanzierung dieses Krieges
durch Putin zu beschenken schneiden
deswegen inzwischen das zehnte
Sanktionspaket deswegen bezieht Europa
heute keine Kohle kein Öl kein Gas mehr
aus Russland weil wir der Auffassung
sind wir küssen Russland daran hindern
diesen Krieg vorzusetzen auch das ist
Diplomatie ich würde mir übrigens bei
der Gelegenheit im elften Sanktionspaket
wünschen dass wir die Liste der nicht
mehr importierten energetischen
Ressourcen künftig in Europa auch auf
Uran erweitern dass wir ein echter
Vorschlag für das elfte Sanktionsrecht
und das ist genau der Punkt wo wir uns
unterscheiden
wir frönen nicht der Naivität des bloßen
Forderns sondern wir wollen Russland
dazu bringen diesen Krieg zu beenden und
dafür in Verhandlung zu treten und
deswegen gibt es keine Alternative zu
einem Weg der sagt auf der einen Seite
sicherstellen dass es nicht überrannt
wird und auf der anderen Seite alles
dafür tun dass dieser Politik von Putin
diese verbrecherische Strategie ein
anderes Land zu überfallen dabei auf
eine
Kriegsstrategie der Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit zu setzen das ist Vorsatz
und gemacht gibt es keine Alternative
will man diese Verbrechen beenden dann
muss man diesen Weg gehen man muss so
ausrüsten und man muss politischen Druck
entwickeln damit endlich verhandelt wird
um diese Verbrechen zu beenden
jugendreutin war das hier am Rednerpult
teilweise in sozusagen im Dialog mit
Gregor Gysi wer sich übrigens selbst ein
Bild davon machen möchte was Deutschland
an Unterstützungsleistung bisher
geleistet hat militärisch aber auch
darüber hinaus es gibt auf der Seite der
Bundesregierung eine Liste die auch
aktualisiert wird auch auf der Seite des
Entwicklungshilfe Ministeriums
beispielsweise sind 270 Stromgeneratoren
geliefert worden um auch die
Infrastruktur aufrecht zu erhalten bzw
wieder die Stromversorgung zu
gewährleisten
weil ihre Fraktion hat vier Minuten
Redezeit das können wir jetzt hier
miteinander dienen so klappt das nicht
sie haben das Wort Peter Bistro für die
AFD steht vorne
Kollegen Liebe Kollege Trittin sie haben
hier bewundernswert versucht jetzt
gerade einen ein Teil zu treiben sogar
zwischen die Linken aber auch zwischen
die Linken und und die rechte Seite des
Parlaments und Herr Doktor war
sie haben das äh
nliches das ist das ist nein das ist
automatisch für die für die ganze
Diskussion der der letzten Zeit ja
das ist das sind das sind Denkmuster aus
dem 19 Jahrhundert dieses dieses
ja im 20 hat es noch vorgesetzt aber wir
leben im 21 Jahrhundert ja und dieses
links rechts Spektrum ist längst
überholt wo wir was wollen wir leben wo
wir im Leben ist nein wir haben hier die
Menschen die auf die Straße gehen und es
ist den völlig egal ob das Sarah Wagen
nicht oder Jürgen Elsässer oder Peter
Bistro in München dazu aufrufen die
demonstrieren für Frieden und gegen den
Krieg was wir hier haben ist eine
horizontale Teilung des politischen
Spektrums das sind die Menschen da unten
und die globalen Eliten da oben und das
erleben Sie jeden Tag wenn sie das nicht
verstehen dann verfolgen sie das noch
ein paar Tage dann wird sie die Realität
einholen
[Applaus]
haben Sie denn nicht darüber nachgedacht
warum wir hier immer auf Antrag der
Opposition
diskutieren warum sich Deutschland nicht
an diesen Krieg beteiligen soll warum
wir keine Waffen liefern sollen und
stattdessen Frieden schaffen sollen
weil die Bundesregierung eben aus
Parteien besteht die ihre Wahl
Versprechen gebrochen haben die lieber
Krieg führen als Frieden zu schaffen und
weil sie die Grundsätze der Außenpolitik
der Nachkriegszeit komplett über den
Bord geworfen haben
[Applaus]
sie betreiben hier genau die Spaltung
der Gesellschaft wie die anderen
Kollegen sie haben hier auch noch
angesprochen hier wissen sie was sie
machen jeder der sie als unfähige Person
kritisiert das sagen sie ja das ist eine
gitimierung der Institution nein sie
dele geht die mir an diese Institution
durch ihr Verhalten und durch ihre
Unfähigkeit
[Applaus]
noch mal sie alle haben ihre Wähler
belogen und betrogen und sie alle
regieren jeden Tag über die Köpfe der
Menschen hinweg die Menschen
demonstrieren zu zig tausenden für den
Frieden gegen den Krieg und was machen
sie sie rufen sie liefern Waffen und die
Familien die Demonstranten das ist doch
ihre Taktik das haben sie hier gerade in
dieser Diskussion jetzt hat sie die
Familie die Menschen dafür dass sie für
den für den Frieden demonstrieren
FDP sie kaufen Waffen für die Ukraine
aus Steuergeldern von Menschen die das
nicht wollen warum richten Sie nicht
eine Freiwilligen vor dann können Sie
Slava Ukraine nennen und lassen sie da
alle einzahlen die diesen Krieg
unterstützen wollen wenn das die
Mehrheit ist so wie Sie behaupten und
müssen sie doch ganz entspannt sein sind
sie aber nicht weil sie wissen dass das
nicht geht weil sie die Mehrheit nicht
hinter ihnen haben
[Applaus]
die Mehrheit der Menschen ist gegen
diesen Krieg
die Mehrheit der Menschen wünscht sich
Frieden
und
wir alle die für den Frieden eintreten
müssen und uns hier auch noch als
Agenten moskaust beschimpfen lassen und
von wem von Leuten die von den
Amerikanern gesteuert bezahlt und
überwacht werden liebe Freunde das ist
das was Sie hier die ganze Zeit machen
und
dagegen wenden wir uns von der AFD
offensichtlich jetzt auch viele von den
Linken und dafür sind wir denn dankbar
danke schön
[Applaus]
die Kollegin Dr Maria agnesstrack
Zimmermann hat jetzt das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion
Paartherapie zwischen rechts und links
da gibt es vielleicht eine extra
Aufwandsentschädigung für sie beide
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen frau Präsidentin
der Auftritt auf der Bühne am Ende der
Pro russischen Friedensdemo das
nachhaltigste was geblieben ist und was
in Erinnerung bleibt ist der Auftritt
der Protagonisten auf der Bühne Sarah
Wagenknecht
extraktionsvorsitzende der Linken ihr
Gatte Oskar Lafontaine unter anderem
Ex-Mitglied der Linken Alice Schwarzer
Ex Ikone der Frauenbewegung bei der das
Thema Vergewaltigung von ukrainischen
Frauen die Welt wartet vergebens darauf
auf deren berechtigten Aufschrei und
General Fahrt militärischer ex-berater
der Kanzlerin alle vier tänzelnd auf der
Bühne Händchen haltend zu John Lennons
Gift peace a chance meine Damen und
Herren was für ein zynischer auftritt
und das ganze das Ganze garniert mit
bekannten Rechtsextremisten und
Holocaust Leugnern und ihre
Fraktionsvorsitzende Frau Mohammed Ali
fand das ganz klasse sie ist heute auch
nicht da das ist erstaunlich der Schwund
ist offensichtlich meine Damen und
Herren heute forderte Linksfraktion
diplomatische Gespräche mit Russland und
was human klingt ist in Moskau aber ein
Arrangement mit Massenmördern voll daran
und Vergewaltiger eine Diplomatie die
ins leer läuft weil Wladimir Putin jeden
Tag betonen dass er die Ukraine
auslöschen will dass er eben nicht
bereit ist die völkerrechtswidrige
Gesetzen Gebiete zu verlassen
meine Damen und Herren diejenigen die
das narrativputins Verbreiten Russland
sei vom Westen bedroht worden und hätte
sich mit dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
doch nur erwehren müssen und diejenigen
die von der Ukraine Kompromisse erwarten
das sind die die bereit sind die Ukraine
zu opfern und wer der Ukraine Waffen
militärisches Material verwehrt der
spricht der Ukraine schlicht das Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung ab und warum tun
sie das weil sie es nicht interessiert
dass 1.300 Kilometer von hier ein Volk
hingerichtet wird weil sie in Ruhe
gelassen werden wollen weil sie wollen
dass sich die Ukraine fügt sie verraten
damit das Völkerrecht das nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg sicherstellen wollte
dass nie wieder ein Land nie wieder ein
Land ein anderes überfällt und grenzen
überschiebt sie nehmen den Kauf dass die
ukrainische Kultur die Sprache die
Identität ausgelöscht wird und noch
schlimmer sie ignorieren die brutale
Realität die russische Streitkräfte
gehen Vertrauen voller Härte vor und ich
werde Ihnen jetzt mal ein Beispiel
bringen in irpin legten sie nach einem
Massaker den Hingerichteten Müttern ihre
weinenden Kinder auf den Bauch und als
ukrainische Soldaten diesen Kindern
helfen wollten sterben auch sie weil
russische Soldaten zwischen den Müttern
und ihren Kindern Sprengfallen
angebracht haben dieses unfassbare
Grauen geschieht genauso lange bis Putin
entscheidet dass es aufhören muss und
deswegen sitzt dort der richtige
Adressat für alle friedensappelle
manifeste Demonstrationen dort sitzt der
Täter in Moskau und dieser Täter hört
nicht auf die Sprache dieser Form von
Diplomatie und das geträllere von
friedensliedern er versteht eben nur die
Sprache der Stärke und Gespräche können
auch nur aus der Stärke herausgeführt
werden und das alleine entscheidet die
Ukraine und ganz sicher nicht Herr Gisi
und deshalb
speziell wichtig die weltgemeinschaften
wer will was Herr Falle will was und
also er möchte nämlich an eine
Zwischenfrage stellen möchten Sie die
Zulassung
und deshalb ist es wir wollen nicht
übertreiben deshalb ist es so
existenziell wichtig dass sich die
Weltgemeinschaft hinter die Ukraine
stellt und sie wirtschaftlich humanitär
aber eben auch mit Waffen unterstützt
damit dieser Terror endlich gestoppt
wird und die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine wieder vollständig hergestellt
wird jedes abtreten von Gebiet wäre ein
Erfolg Russland meine Damen und Herren
das ist das Problem das ist das Problem
was wir haben und das ist die wahre
Bedrohung für den Frieden in Deutschland
in Europa ja und in der ganzen Welt
meine Damen und Herren
Thomas Mann hat
1941 aus dem Exil heraus in einer
Radioansprache an das Deutsche Reich
sich gewandt als ich die
Nationalsozialisten darüber beschwert
haben der Kriegseintritt der USA und die
Wehrhaftigkeit der Engländer würden den
Krieg verlängern seit 82 82 Jahre später
trifft es immer noch den Punkt und
erklärt wie verbrecherische Despoten
sind Zitat sie verlangen Frieden sie die
vom Blute des eigenen Volkes und anderer
Volker triefen sie Wagen ist diese Worte
in den Mund zu nehmen damit meinen sie
Unterwerfung die Legalisierung ihrer
Verbrechen die Hinnahme des menschlich
unerträglichen aber das ist nicht
möglich mit einem Hitler gibt es keinen
Frieden weil er des Friedens von Grund
auf unfähig und weil dieses Wort in
seinem Munde nur eine schmutzige
krankhafte Lüge ist nach 82 Jahren
ticken verbrecherische Despoten immer
noch so
für die FDP die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses hier diese
Aussprache jubeingarten erwarten wir
jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren die Ukraine steht in der
schwersten Krise ihrer kurzen Existenz
als unabhängiger Staat zum dritten Mal
muss dieses leitgeprüfte Volk um sein
Überleben kämpfen gegen Stalin gegen
Hitler und jetzt gegen Putin die Ukraine
hat gerade den schwersten Winter ihre
Geschichte überlebt aber sie zahlt einen
ungeheuren Preis dafür bei den Kämpfen
um bachmut bei den 10.000 Toten bei den
russischen Terrorangriffen auf
Infrastruktur und Wohngebiete in diesem
Überlebenskampf hat das ukrainische Volk
ein Recht darauf dass wir uns auch im
Deutschen Bundestag mit seinem Schicksal
und der möglichen Beendigung der Kämpfe
beschäftigen aber das muss angemessen in
voller Solidarität und mit aller
denkbaren Unterstützung für die Ukraine
für den ukrainischen Überlebenskampf
erfolgen
der heute debattierte Antrag der Linken
erfüllt diese Ansprüche nicht er ist
vielmehr ein Dokument der Kaltherzigkeit
der arroganten Überheblichkeit und der
ideologischen Verblendung in der ihnen
verbirgt sich eine tragische
Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber dem Schicksal
der Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine der
vermeintliche Aufruf zum Frieden ist
nichts anderes als ein Aufruf an die
Ukraine zur Kapitulation zur
Unterwerfung unter den russischen
Aggressor
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Voraussetzungen für das Überleben der
Ukraine ist die militärische Hilfe der
freien Nationen nicht als Selbstzweck
nicht zur kriegsverlängerung sondern um
der Ukraine überhaupt die Möglichkeit zu
geben weiter zu existieren wer diesen
Zusammenhang leugnet spielt das Spiel
Putins und er oder sie tut das bewusst
und unter den kaufname der militärischen
und politischen Vernichtung der Ukraine
damit reiht sich der Antrag ein in
unzählige Aufrufe und Demonstrationen
der letzten Wochen es ist beschämend wie
sich bei diesem Thema die
rechtsradikalien in der AFD und die
Rechtsradikalen bei den Linken verbünden
und in gemeinsamen aufrufen äußern
Forderungen nach Waffenstillstand und
Frieden ohne zu sagen wie sie erreicht
werden sollen sie sind billig und
oberflächlich das ist nicht unser Weg
wir haben uns als Regierungskoalition an
die Parteien die sie tragen in den
letzten Jahren nicht leicht gemacht auf
dem Weg die Ukraine zu unterstützen ohne
Kriegspartei zu werden und ohne einen
europäischen oder gar weltweiten
Konflikt auszulösen aber wir sind dieser
Linie Unterführung des Bundeskanzlers
erfolgreich nachgekommen haben Waffen in
die Ukraine für annähernd drei
Milliarden Euro geliefert und zwar die
Waffen die die Ukraine jeweils dringend
brauchte Panzer ehemals sowjetischer
Bauart bis heute das Rückgrat der
ukrainischen Panzerwaffe modernste
Artillerie und die besten
luftabwehrwaffen der Welt die die
massive Bedrohung durch russische
jagdbombe und Drohnen eindämmen dazu
große Mengen an Munition Logistik
Panzerabwehr und in vertriever Waffen
jetzt kommen mehrere leopard-bataione im
europäischen Verbund dazu wir werden
diese Linie weiterführen die Ukraine vor
einer militärischen Niederlage bewahren
und alles dafür tun dass Russland die
auslosigkeit
seines Tuns einsieht und an den
Verhandlungstisch kommt wir tun alles
was dazu notwendig ist und wir tun es so
lange es notwendig ist
meine Damen und Herren Waffenstillstand
und Friedensschluss bleiben
selbstverständlich Ziele der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion auch wenn das im
Moment weit entfernt scheint aber mit
einer freien Ukraine und nicht zu den
Bedingungen Russlands und dann müssen
auch dort die Verantwortung für diesen
russischen Angriffskrieg und die dort
begangenen Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit benannt werden müssen
sich die Verantwortlichen vor einem
tribunalverantwortlichen verantworten
allen voran Wladimir Putin
auf diesem Weg lassen wir die Ukraine
nicht allein und es ist beschämend dass
ich die Linke diesem Weg der Solidarität
der Freiheit und der Gerechtigkeit nicht
anschließt
sie berufen sich bei den Linken auf die
Freiheitlichen Traditionen der deutschen
Arbeiterbewegung wir alle in diesem Haus
wissen dass über diesem Anspruch ohnehin
schon der Schatten der sed-ditratur
liegt aus dem sie hervorgegangen sind
und jetzt geben sie diese Traditionen
schon wieder auf und geben der Kälte der
militärischen Macht den voll zu den
Vorzug ein erneutes historisches
Versagen ich kann nur an sie appellieren
ändern Sie diesen Weg trennen Sie sich
von denen die mit dem Friedenswillen der
Menschen Schindler oder treiben und
nehmen Sie diesen unzähligen Antrag
zurück er ist das Themas nicht würdig
vielen Dank
für die SPD in Richtung der
Linksfraktion
und jetzt hat die cdu/csu-fraktion in
Personen von Jürgen hat noch mal die
Möglichkeit auf diesen Antrag zu
reagieren erste Fassung dieses heute
hier vorliegenden Antrags gelesen habe
habe ich mir verwundert die Augen
gerieben der Stand runter Antragsteller
Ali Bartsch und ich habe die Namen
cupala Weidel vermisst weil das wäre ein
guter erster gemeinsamer Antrag von
links und rechts außen in diesem
Bundestag gewesen in der Tradition des
demonstrationsaufrufs vom vergangenen
Samstag
wir haben
die
linke Fraktion in einer Situation in der
sie den Drohnen Untergang vor Augen
sieht und sie fischt im drüben und hat
mit dem
neofaschistischen Beifang den sie dabei
einräumt kein Problem das ist die
Fraktion die alle anderen demokratischen
Fraktionen des Hauses stets mahnt klare
Kante zeigen gegenüber rechts außen die
das genau jetzt verletzt und kein
Problem damit hat dass Leo Faschisten
ihre Politik auch öffentlich unterstützt
möchte ich möchte zu den den Inhalten
kommen im Zentrum des Antrags steht der
sofortige Waffenstillstand
ein sofortiger Waffenstillstand würde
bedeuten dass russische Truppen
dauerhaft nämlich mindestens bis zum
Ende des Waffenstillstands vermutlich
darüber hinaus auf fremden nämlich
ukrainischen Boden stehen und das
Russland aus der Größe des Landes
seine Truppen in der Ukraine
stabilisieren und stärken könnte
der Waffenstillstand würde in erster
Linie dem russischen Angriffskrieg
dienen und deswegen ist es auch
ungewöhnlich verwunderlich dass viele in
Moskau diese Überlegungen genauso teilen
und dass das auch Teil dieses
chinesischen Vorschlags gewesen ist
Diplomatie hat in diesem Konflikt eine
große Chance gehabt die Entscheidung
Diplomatie statt Waffen haben wir 2014
getroffen ich erinnere mich an intensive
Diskussionen am Rande der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz in Washington auch
im Auswärtigen Amt mit Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus dem Kongress bei der
parteienrepublikaner wie Demokraten wie
gesagt haben wir müssen die Ukraine
aufrüsten und den Preis für Protein in
die Höhe zu treiben wir Deutsche auch
wir in der cdu/csu haben gesagt wir
wollen keine militärische Eskalation
sondern wir wollen eine diplomatische
Lösung normandieformat Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel Präsident macron gemeinsam
mit dem russischen und dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten diese acht Jahre hat
Russland genutzt um sich vorzubereiten
auf diesen Angriff gegen die Ukraine
wir sollten jetzt nicht den Fehler
machen wieder zu sagen Diplomatie vor
Waffenlieferungen sondern beides muss
möglich sein und ich sage umgekehrt ich
glaube je stärker die Ukraine ist desto
näher kommen wir an den Punkt an dem man
im Kreml einsieht dass die Fortführung
des Kampfes ein größeres Risiko für
Putin und den gremme darstellt als das
Eintreten in tatsächliche ernsthafte
Verhandlungen und ich bin davon
überzeugt wenn dieser Punkt erreicht ist
wird man auch in Kiew und bei allen
unterstützenden Nationen zum Ergebnis
kommen dass das der richtige Zeitpunkt
ist leider sind wir an diesem Zeitpunkt
noch nicht
es fehlt der Ukraine leider an Kraft
jetzt kraftvoll diesem diesem Angriff zu
widerstehen in dem früher ich fürchte
dass wir in den letzten drei Monaten
eher eine Stärkung der russischen
Truppen erlebt haben weil wir zu
zögerlich waren mit Waffen die Frauen
und wir haben in der Europäischen Union
das steht am 20 März auf der
Tagesordnung des auswärtigen Rates wenn
dies richtig verstanden habe den
Initiative von Estland einige Milliarden
zur Verfügung zu stellen um Munition
bereitzustellen für die Ukraine und ich
habe in diesem Zusammenhang die
Bundesregierung gefragt eigentlich geht
es ja nicht um Geld sondern es geht um
die Frage wo sind die wo ist die
Munition wo sind konkret die
panzerhaubitzengranaten die die Ukraine
jetzt dringend braucht ich habe die
Frage gestellt kann die deutsche
Bundesregierung ausschließen dass es in
Deutschland ungenutzte Kapazitäten zur
Herstellung solcher Granaten gibt obwohl
wir doch alle wissen und alle unsere
Partner sagen wir brauchen die und ich
habe bisher darauf keine Antwort
erhalten und ich erwarte dass die
Bundesregierung sicherstellt dass alle
Kapazitäten in Deutschland bei der
Rüstungsindustrie und in der Bundeswehr
genutzt werden und der Ukraine die
notwendige Munition zur Verfügung zu
stellen damit wir eben an den Punkt
kommen wo die Diplomatie tatsächlich
wieder eine Chance hat
möchte die letzten Minute meiner Rede
darauf verwenden vielleicht noch mal
mich der Frage zu widmen wie die Leute
Bevölkerung das deutsche Volk zu diesem
Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine steht
erstens glaube ich dass es nur ganz ganz
wenige gibt einige wenige von denen
waren am Samstag vor Tagen hier in
Berlin die den Sieg Russland über die
Ukraine wollen
ich glaube aber dass es in Deutschland
eine doch große Zahl von Menschen gibt
die der Meinung ist wenn wir Putin nur
das geben was er will kommt der Friede
zurück nach Europa und wir haben Ruhe
sie billigen nicht diesen Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine aber sie
glauben wenn die Ukraine nachgeben würde
und wir die Ukraine darin bestärken wäre
der Konflikt zu Ende
ich fürchte dass dies eine
Fehleinschätzung ist die Antwort die wir
geben müssen ist viel bitterer nämlich
dass wir sagen in dem Augenblick wo
Russland Erfolg hat bei der Eroberung
der Ukraine geht der große
Konflikt in Europa erst los und früher
oder später werden wir erleben das
molder Georgien Baltikum
am Ende sogar die NATO von Putin
herausgefordert wird wenn er sich durch
Erfolge ermutigt fühlte diese Richtung
zu gehen das ist leider eine bitterere
Wahrheit als das Versprechen gibt doch
Putin was er will und dann gibt es Ruhe
aber es ist wie ich fürchte die Wahrheit
und deswegen müssen wir die Ukraine nach
Kräften unterstützen dass sie diesen
Kampf gewinnen kann und ich hoffe dass
wir in den nächsten Wochen auch mehr
Dynamik und mehr Schwung enthalten
insbesondere seitens der Bundesregierung
Jürgen hart war das für die
Unionsfraktion der außenpolitische
Sprecher er hat die Kapazitäten der
Rüstungsindustrie angesprochen heute
morgen in seiner Regierungserklärung hat
der Bundeskanzler der Rüstungsindustrie
Hilfen zugesagt damit sie eine laufende
Produktion von wichtigen waffengeräten
und Munitionen aufbauen können
die Linksfraktion hat heute ein sehr
knappen und kurzen Antrag zum russischen
Angriffskrieg vorgelegt und dabei sage
und schreibe zwei Forderungen vorgelegt
sie fordern zum einen die humanitäre
Unterstützung der geflüchteten aus dem
Kriegsgebieten so weit so
selbstverständlich und sie fordern einen
Waffenstillstand und friedensverhandlung
was die aber nicht sagen ist wieder Weg
dorthin aussehen soll und wie man den
Kriegsverbrecher Putin eigentlich dazu
bringen möchte die Waffen schweigen zu
lassen ohne dass sich die Ukraine selbst
aufgeben muss wie kommt man zu einem
tragfähigen Frieden bei dem Putin und
auch seine Nachfolger
alle Wahl davon Abstand nehmen die
Ukraine gewaltsam vernichten zu wollen
dazu sagen sie überhaupt gar nichts und
die Leisten seit einem Jahr eben keinen
Beitrag dazu eine ernsthafte
demokratische und diplomatische Lösung
vorzulegen werden sich die ganze Welt
den Kopf darüber zerbricht
diese Sprachlosigkeit wird leider
begleitet von einer gefährlichen
Realitätsverweigerung es ist Putin der
mit der Methode Gewalt seine
imperialistischen Interessen
durchzusetzen versucht ganz egal wie
viele Leute er dafür opfern muss und sie
ignorieren eben noch immer dass der
eigentliche Kriegstreiber in Moskau
sitzt und das ist das eigentliche
Problem denn sonst würden sie ja
verstehen dass sie ihren Appell
Diplomatie statt Panzer an niemanden
sonst richten sollten als an Vladimir
Putin aber diese Realität die passt halt
nicht ins Weltbild weil der Schurke eben
hier nicht in den USA sitzt sondern in
Moskau ihre Realitätsverweigerung die
hat gefährliche Auswirkungen sie führt
dazu dass die Menschen noch mehr Angst
haben
Angst musikkapital schlagen sondern auch
die extreme Rechte da drüben und es
führt eben dazu dass noch mehr Menschen
offene Ohren entwickeln für eine
brandgefährliche Täter Opfer Umkehr von
der Putin profitiert
der Wagenknecht tingelt mit
Relativierungen von putinsraditionismus
und menschenverachtender Verbrechen
durch die Talkshows und das entzückt
natürlich nicht nur den Kreml sondern
auch seine rechtsextremen Verbündeten im
Rest von Europa und darum ist es eben
auch kein Zufall dass viele
rechtsradikale am vergangenen Wochenende
Seite an Seite mit Mitgliedern der
Linkspartei und putinfreunden durch
Berlin marschiert sind
noch einmal kurz zur mitschreiben für
Sie was der Rest der demokratischen
Fraktion seit einem Jahr tut mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine humanitär
finanziell und militärisch verfolgende
gemeinsam mit den internationalen
Partnern eben die Strategie um Putin an
den Verhandlungstisch zu zwingen wir
helfen der Ukraine sich gegen die
Aggression Putins zu wehren und so soll
Putin eben ein machtpolitisches
Interesse entwickeln zu verhandeln statt
zu schießen und so wollen wir die
Friedensordnung in Europa wieder
herstellen und wegen dieses
militärischen teils in der Unterstützung
werden sie ist der Bundesregierung vor
kriegslöstern zu sein und das ohne eine
konkrete alternative vorzulegen wie man
denn sonst zu Verhandlungen kommen soll
und das zeigt eben dass sie sich gerne
leicht machen aber das eben
verantwortungslos in dieser Position und
Situation die Wahrheit ist doch ohne die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
wäre die Ukraine schon längst von der
Landkarte gestrichen und die Lehren aus
diesem Krieg werden gewesen erstens für
die Demokratisierung wirst du als
post-juvetrischer Staat blutig bezahlen
und die EU lässt sich im Stich zweitens
hol die Atomwaffen wenn du deine
Integrität schützen willst und wenn du
schon welche hast dann gib sie niemals
ab und drittens als Adresse kannst du
sogar mitten in Europa gewaltsam Grenzen
verschieben und es passiert ja
eigentlich im Kern gar nichts zu was für
einem Frieden würde das
[Musik]
fürchten spielen sie weiterhin die
militärische Unterstützung und die
Diplomatie gegeneinander aus die Wiese
muss aber heißen Diplomatie und
militärische Hilfe für die Ukraine liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen so eigentlich
bräuchtet genau jetzt eine linke Partei
die sich kritisch mit dem jettischen
Imperialismus auseinandersetzt die
Demokratie Feindlichkeit und
Revisionismus klar zurückweist
als die aufrichtige Wege für einen Tag
gegen Frieden beschreibt und sie sind
diese Partei leider nicht das ist der
traurig denn für Antifaschismus und
Frieden zu sein das heißt Widerstand
gegen Putin zu unterstützen
[Applaus]
für die AFD hat Eugen Schmidt das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Landsleute
kein Krieg der Geschichte hätte so
leicht verhindert werden können wir der
in der Ukraine
so schnell nach dem Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion Zusagen getätigt wurden dass
sich die NATO nicht nach Osten ausdehnen
dürfe so schnell wurden diese auch
gebrochen
Russland Schuld am Krieg ist nicht
bestreitbar aber es muss dabei beachtet
werden dass seine berechtigten
Sicherheitsinteressen missachtet wurden
ein Jahr ist es nur her dass der Krieg
im Osten Europas begann was ist seither
geschehen
hunderttausende tote
unendliches Leid und gravierende
finanzielle Folgen für Millionen
Deutsche die deutsche Regierung aber
agiert wie ein Schlafwandler getrieben
von der skalationsdruck und
Kriegstreibern die unser Land in den
Abgrund führen
statt die Lage endlich nüchtern zu
analysieren und unsere nationalen
Interessen zu vertreten lassen Sie die
ampelkriegstreiber von anderen am
Nasenring durch die magnese führen die
Lieferung deutschen Kampfpanzer an die
Ukraine waren weitere
tiefpunktpolitischen Unvermögens was
wird dieser Bundesregierung wie wird die
Krieg weiter eskalieren
Kampfjets oder sogar eigene deutsche
Besatzungen
sie schüren das vorher der skalation
indem sie einen zerstörten Panzer vor
der russischen Botschaft aufstellen
über 50.000 Teilnehmer an der
friedensnehmer am Wochenende haben die
Nase voll von ihren Provokationen
in einer Krisensituation wie dieser
sollte die Stärkung unserer
Wirtschaftskraft und die Sicherung
unserer Energie und ressourcenversorgung
eine hohe Priorität haben
stattdessen beteiligen wir uns an einem
selbst zerstörerischen sanktions das
unsere Wirtschaft mehr schadet als der
Russlands
man kann und muss mit der russischen
Seite verhandeln dass dies möglich sein
kann haben wir in der Frühphase des
Krieges sehen können
beide Seiten führten damals
Verhandlungen und standen kurz vor einer
Einigung
Russlands hätte sich nach diesem Plänen
zurückgezogen die Ukraine wäre neutrales
Gebiet geworden leider wurde ein
Abschluss von den Profiteuren des
Krieges aus den USA und Großbritannien
blockiert
ich schließe mit einem Zitat von Helmut
Schmidt unter dem ist diesen Krieg
möglicherweise nicht gegeben hätte
lieber 100 Stunden und sonst verhandeln
als eine Minute schießen
meine Damen und Herren von der
Bundesregierung stoppen sie dir dort
bringen den Waffenlieferungen und setzen
Sie sich für einen Waffenstillstand und
Gespräche ein vielen Dank
von der AFD hat gerade noch mal die
Demonstration zu der Sahra Wagenknecht
und alles schwarzer unter anderem ja am
Samstag in Berlin aufgerufen haben
angesprochen und die Angaben über die
Teilnehmerzahl die geht tatsächlich sehr
weit auseinander der Veranstalter sprach
von 50.000
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern und die
Polizei von 13000 Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen den Kollegen
Schmidt von den von der AFD da empfehle
ich mal die
Sichtung des Budapester Memorandums wo
eindeutig drin steht das Russland sich
als Garantie macht für die nationale
Integrität der Ukraine in ihren Grenzen
inklusive krimen einzusetzen hat und
eigentlich müsste Russland gerade gegen
sich selber kämpfen wenn es sich an
seine Verträge halten würde die es mit
der Ukraine unter anderem aber auch mit
dem besten geschlossen hat und wenn hier
irgendjemand Sicherheits
Sicherheiten gefährdet dann ist das
Russland ich kann mich nicht daran
erinnern dass es irgendjemanden gab aus
der gesamten nato-familie der jemals die
Integrität Russlands in Frage gestellt
hatten es macht mich wirklich zornig
dass sie immer wieder versuchen mit
ihren narrativen über afd-tv die
Bevölkerung über irgendeinen Unsinn der
wirklich nicht stimmt zu infizieren und
da müssen wir alle gegen kämpfen
der Antrag der Linken ist deshalb auch
heute für mich im besten Fall naiv im
schlechtesten Fall ein Trojanisches
Pferd für die Interessen des russischen
Präsidenten ich sage es deshalb deutlich
jeder von uns in diesem Hohen Hause
möchte lieber Diplomatie statt Panzer
aber die harte Wahrheit ist doch dass
der Krieg nur durch Diplomatie und
Panzer beendet werden kann aus
russischer Sicht ist eine militärisch
schwache Ukraine nämlich kein
gleichwertiger Verhandlungspartner
sondern sie ist ein leichtes Opfer für
den russischen Imperialismus und dass
die Ukraine
sich so tapfer verteidigt hat haben in
Russland diese ganzen Strategen die das
ganze vom Zaun gebrochen haben nie für
möglich gehalten da brauchen Sie gar
nicht verschämt in Ihren Rechner zu
schauen sie sind der größte Freiheit
hier die ganze Zeit gewesen Herr Kollege
es ist einfach mal Fakt das Russland die
Ukraine überfallen hat obwohl sämtliche
Präsidenten Kanzler Regierungschefs die
gesamten Regierungschef der westlichen
Welt versucht haben genau dieses zu
verhindern und sie machen sich mit
Leuten Gemeinden die der Meinung sind
das ist in Ordnung ist wenn in einem
Krieg Frauen vergewaltigt werden sie
machen sich das ist ihre eigene Partei
Freundin die das in dem außen vertreten
hat und ich habe mich selten so geschämt
für den Auftritt von ihr bei hart aber
fair aber wir haben selten Zeit sowas
anzuschauen der Faktencheck ist mir da
relativ egal weil ich nämlich
zufälligerweise auch sehr sehr viele
Fakten in meinem Hirn habe und es war
schlichten ergreifend peinlich für ihre
gesamte Partei was Sarah Wagenknecht
sich dort geleistet hat
die SPD ist dankbar ohne Ende des Oskar
Lafontaine in irgendwann den Rücken
gekehrt hat und dass er auch in der
schwuppler Ecke bald andere Menschen
sich beschäftigen kann der hat sie
selber im Saarland im Stich gelassen ich
darf Sie daran erinnern viel Spaß mit
diesen Freunden die sie da haben und die
da drüben sind laut Hufeisen Theorie
heute aber ganz ganz besonders bei ihnen
angedockt und ich finde das fürchterlich
peinlich das ausgerechnet die
Linkspartei und die AFD hier im Hohen
Haus von uns verlangen dass wir für Sie
eine Paartherapie machen wie meine
Kollegin stark Zimmermann vorhin schon
angemerkt hat das ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe ja aber versuchen Sie sich
wirklich und das kann ich Ihnen nur
raten von den Rechten in diesem Haus
abzugrenzen weil ansonsten wird sie
wirklich niemand mehr davor retten
können dass sie in der politischen
Bedeutungslosigkeit Deutschlands
gelangen werden und fragen Sie doch mal
ganz offen gesagt was starten wie das
die aus dem Baltikum die Finnland oder
Polen von ihrem Antrag halten die
Antwort können Sie gerne am Moskau
weiterleiten ich gehe davon aus dass ihr
Draht dort immer noch am besten ist und
wenn ich daran erinnern darf Vladimir
Putin hat kurz nach dem Ausbruch des
ukrainekriegs im Fernsehen in Russland
gesagt dass er die Machtverhältnisse von
1990 wiederherstellen möchte und
Vladimir Putin weiß was er gesagt hat er
hat damit auch Ostdeutschland gemeint
und wer der Meinung ist dass die DDR
wiedererstehen soll das können
eigentlich in diesem Haus nur sie wollen
weil sie dann offensichtlich zu ihrer
alten macht Fülle zurückkehren wollen
hier werden uns mit aller Macht
dagegenstellen die Freiheit Europas und
der Bundesrepublik zu verteidigen das
ist Aufgabe dieser Bundesregierung und
der die sie tragenden koalitionsfraktion
von den Liberalen hier mit
der Linken die dort wenn ich die
Reaktionen richtig gedeutet habe nicht
so richtig gut ankam nicht überraschend
nächster jetzt für die Sozialdemokratie
ist
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir debattieren
im Deutschen Bundestag heute über einen
Antrag der Fraktion DIE LINKE diese
möchte ich mit Ihnen einmal genauer
durchgehen nicht Wort für Wort keine
Sorge aber doch einige auffällige
Passagen
DIE LINKE fordert ein Ende des Krieges
eine Aussage die wir im Grundsatz
mittragen nach 371 Tagen des brutalen
russischen Angriffskrieges gegen die
Ukraine wünschen sich alle
demokratischen Partner einen Frieden in
der Ukraine in Europa weiter im Text
heißt es sinngemäß mit Frieden
beziehungsweise über Frieden zusammen
mit europäischen und nicht europäischen
Staaten zum Beispiel Brasilien zu
verhandeln auch hier im Grundsatz in
Ordnung wir müssen das breite Spektrum
diplomatischer Möglichkeiten weiter
ausreizen zum Beispiel mit China oder
Indien in bilateralen gesprächsformaten
oder im Rahmen von multilater treffen
wie geht 20 war schon passiert macht
unsere Außenministerin unser
Bundeskanzler unser
Bundesverteidigungsminister erlauben Sie
mir eine weitere Stelle aus dem Antrag
wiederzugeben und dann möchte ich fair
sein
sie sagen die humanitäre Hilfe für die
Ukraine muss verstärkt werden und dann
bitte ich auch Fairness von ihrer Seite
uns gegenüber und auch von Ihnen Herr
Gregor Gysi denn mein Kollege Jürgen
Jürgen Trittin hat es auf den Punkt
gebracht es ist einer unserer
Schwerpunkte außen Sicherheitspolitik
auch in Entwicklung zum Arbeitspolitik
die Ukraine humanitär und auch im
Bereich der Katastrophenhilfe zu
unterstützen aktuell seit Kriegsbeginn
mit 12,5 Milliarden Euro und wenn sie
sagen dass wir nicht bereit sind dann
ist das die Unwahrheit und ist die Lüge
und muss auch so zu Protokoll gegeben
werden
so jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu den
Dingen die nicht drin stehen und die
nicht thematisiert werden ob bewusst
oder unbewusst beides bezeichne ich aber
als fahrlässig beginnen wir gleich beim
Titel ihres Antrags der Titel Diplomatie
statt Panzer impliziert zwei
fundamentale falsche Grundannahmen wenn
wir erstens die diplomatischen
Bemühungen hochfahren und zweitens die
Ukraine aufhören militärisch zu
unterstützen dann wäre auch der Logik
der Linksparteien mit einmal der Krieg
gestoppt
das heißt der Krieg wäre zu Ende wenn
wir aufhören würden militärisch zu
unterstützen und ausschließlich
Diplomatie am Tag liegen meiner Meinung
nach meine Damen und Herren ist das ein
Trugschluss und lassen Sie mich ganz
ganz deutlich sagen es wäre der
Todesstoß für eine demokratische freie
und souveräne Ukraine
Diplomatie gab es schon vor dem
russischen vor der russischen Invasion
vor dem
24.22 als die russische Invasion
gestartet hat und in der Zeit wurde
nicht einmal darüber diskutiert Kampf
und Schützenpanzer in naberer Zeit zu
liefern und trotzdem haben alle
diplomatischen versuche nicht geholfen
weil Russland nicht bereit ist von
seinem Kriegsziel abzuweichen das kriegt
sie Putins ist ganz klar die Ukraine ist
kein Staat für Sie es hat kein
Existenzrecht und die ukrainische
Nationen gibt es nicht deshalb
bombardiert Russland Putin seit über
einem Jahr die Ukraine und Schuldige
Menschen verlieren ihr Leben Frauen
werden vergewaltigt Kinder werden in
führt Soldaten auf beiden Seiten
verlieren ihr Leben und ich möchte an
dieser Stelle nicht aufhören diesen
Denkfehler der Linkspartei jetzt weiter
aufzuschließen sondern lassen Sie uns
meinen Szenarien denken vor allem weil
die Leute draußen noch zugucken mir ist
es wichtig nicht vor allem sie zu
überzeugen sondern die Menschen da
draußen die vielleicht noch nicht
hundertprozentig verstehen was wir
gerade tun und das ist auch in Ordnung
weil es nicht selbstverständlich ist in
einer Zeit zu leben aufzuwachsen in
einem Krieg und Waffen liefern zu müssen
Szenario würde Putin aufhören mit dem
Krieg wenn wir keine Waffen mehr liefern
würde es einen echten Waffenstillstand
geben wenn wir aufhören Waffen zu
liefern und die russischen Soldaten
würden sich zurückziehen würde die Angst
viele andere osteuropäischen Länder
Finnlands oder Schweden schwinden und
sie die Garantie bekommen frei vom
autoritären destabilisieren Russen
Einfluss zu sein und ich sage Ihnen ganz
klar die Antworten noch alle drei dieser
Punkte lautet ganz klar nein lassen Sie
mich deutlich sagen Putin würde
weitermachen mit Diplomatie und ohne
Waffen er würde nicht zurückstrecken er
würde weiter versuchen die Ukraine
gewaltsam auseinander zu pflücken und es
ist immer wichtig das zu betonen
Friedensverhandlungen auf jeden Fall auf
Augenhöhe jederzeit lieber gestern als
morgen aber jede Waffenpause russische
Waffenpause würde Putin nutzen um sich
vorzubereiten
auszurüsten aufzurüsten und gewaltsam
bei einem Zeitpunkt X weiterzumachen die
Ukraine von der Landkarte wegzufinden
alles andere ist doch Humbug Liebe
Linksfraktion alles andere zumbuk
deshalb müssen wir die Ukraine
diplomatisch finanziell humanitär aber
auch militärisch unterstützen und zum
Schluss wenn sie wirklich glaubwürdig
solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen wollen eine nachhaltigen echten
Frieden wollen dann distanzieren sie
sich geschlossen von Sahra Wagenknecht
schmeißen sie aus der Fraktion raus und
danach aus der Partei erst dann sind
ihre Worte glaubwürdig und die
Solidarität mit der Ukraine ebenfalls
vielen Dank
ja alles amethovic für die SPD-Fraktion
diesen Antrag den die Linke hier
eingebracht hat nach einem sofortigen
Stopp an Waffenlieferung und nach
friedensverhandlung an die
Bundesregierung der hat sich und das ja
nicht überraschend auch immer mehr zu
einer Wagenknecht Debatte hier
entwickelt die Linke hat alle aber
allerdings kein Rede recht mehr in
dieser Debatte kann also jetzt nicht
mehr direkt reagieren für die Union
dem ganze Landstriche vernichtet wurden
ein Jahr in dem wir alle gerungen haben
um die notwendige Unterstützung für die
mutigen Ukrainerinnen Ukrainer die auch
unsere Freiheit und unsere Sicherheit
verteidigen Putin hat nicht nur die
Ukraine angegriffen er will die
Europäische friedens- und
sicherheitsordnung zerstören diese
europäische Friedensordnung ist
ausformuliert meine Damen und Herren in
Verträge gegossen und da schreiben sie
von der linke in ihrem Antrag von einer
dauerhaften Lösung die die
Sicherheitsinteressen sämtlicher Akteure
berücksichtigen müssen
und schon allein damit wir klar dass sie
nur großen Propaganda verbreiten einem
diktatfrieden das Wort reden und dazu
ist eigentlich in dieser Debatte nun
schon alles gesagt
meine Damen und Herren den
Jahrestag des Überfalls konnte ich mit
Vorsitzenden und Stellvertretern
auswärtiger Ausschüsse aus 13
europäischen Ländern in Kiew verbringen
ein Zeichen der Solidarität in der
Hauptstadt eines freien und
demokratischen Landes die vom Krieg
gezeichnet ist 10.000 Menschen haben
durch sinnlose Zerstörung ihre Wohnung
verloren ich konnte in diese freie Stadt
fahren weil tapfere Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer vor einem Jahr nicht aufgegeben
haben
weil sie diese Stadt verteidigt haben
und dafür müssten sie auch
schrecklichste Gräueltaten ertragen wie
zum Beispiel Butcher und andere Orte
gezeigt haben und damit wird auch eines
klar in den besetzten Gebieten herrscht
kein Frieden auch nicht nach einem
Waffenstillstand den sie fordern eine
besetzten Gebieten sind Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer Menschen zweiter Klasse die
vergewaltigt verschleppt gefoltert
ermordet werden für Kriegsverbrecher
Putin zählt das rechte stärkeren und
nicht Vereinbarungen und Verträge das
hat er nun immer und immer wieder
bewiesen und trotzdem reden sie hier von
links und rechts eben immer noch das
Wort
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Jahrestag in Kiew war für mich ein Tag
der Demut und des Respekts vor der
Leistung die ukrainische Soldaten bisher
kam für Tag vollbracht haben
aber er war auch ein Tag an dem deutlich
wurde dass es auf jede noch so kleine
Unterstützung ankommt das ist auf
Geschwindigkeit ankommt dass jeder Tag
zählt bei der Lieferung von Gerät und
Munition und das ist auf
Durchhaltefähigkeit ankommt die wir
sicherstellen müssen und dass wir dazu
unsere Trägheit überwinden müssen
vor knapp zehn Monaten schon wurde hier
entschieden dass wir einen Teil unserer
Haubitzen liefern den Ukrainern zur
Verfügung stellen zehn Monate und
seitdem ist wieder die Bestellung für
die erschafft für die Ersatzbeschaffung
ausgelöst
seitdem ist wieder eine Bestellung von
Verschleißteilen und Munition erfolgt
zehn Monate meine Damen und Herren in
denen nicht ein bisschen vorausgedacht
wurde in denen in dieser Regierung
offenbar nicht klar wurde auf was es
ankommt ist das die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit von der der Kanzler
heute sprach Estland ergreift jetzt die
Initiative bei der munitionsbeschaffung
weil wir es verschlafen haben und dabei
kommt noch eine wichtige Aufgabe hinzu
nämlich einmal über die nächsten Monate
hinauszudenken vielleicht müssen wir
nicht 14 Haubitzen nachbestellen sondern
vielmehr weil in Zukunft Sicherheit für
die Grünen Ukraine und für ganz Europa
sehr stark durch die Wehrhaftigkeit und
die abschreckungsfähigkeit der
ukrainischen Armee sichergestellt werden
und weitere Realitäten sind klar die
Ukraine ist ein europäisches Land
Neutralität und die Militarisierung
hatten wir schon die Ukraine wird in
eine westliche verteidigungsarchitektur
eingebunden sein dazu braucht es jetzt
endlich kräftigere Schritte unserer
Bundesregierung und dazu braucht es
keine ständige Wiederholung von
russenpropaganda wie wir sie hier von
links und rechts ständig erleben wir
müssen dauerhaft klarmachen dass die
größenwahnsinnigen Träume Putins keine
Aussicht auf Erfolg haben wir müssen
jeden Tag klarmachen dass wir an der
Seite der Ukraine stehen mit allem was
nötig ist bis die Ukraine komplett
befreit ist bis Europa wieder in eine
friedliche Zukunft blicken kann
herzlichen Dank
Thomas Erndte der stellvertretende
Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
hier im Bundestag und ein Redner haben
wir noch zu diesem debattenpunkt der
kommt aus den rein der Sozialdemokraten
Fabian Funke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ich glaube ich weiß
warum sie von den Linken diesen Antrag
gestellt haben er ist die Reaktion auf
das Groteske Schauspiel dass ich am
vergangenen Samstag vor dem
Brandenburger Tor abgespielt hat er ist
ein verzweifelter Versuch das wieder
einzufangen was ich leider nicht mehr
einzufangen lässt und es zeigt wie tief
sie gespalten sind wir haben gesehen am
Wochenende und dann möchte ich kurz auf
die Demo eingehen wie Menschen mit
ukrainischen Symbolen angepöbelt und
beleidigt wurden wie sich auch
Querdenker und rechtsradikale dahinter
versammelt haben und wie von der Bühne
ein eigenartiges zerbild des russischen
Krieges gezeichnet wurde und was haben
wir in den letzten Monaten nicht alles
gehört die Amerikaner haben Schuld am
Überfall Russland auf die Ukraine
Russland möchte eigentlich nur
Sicherheit und die NATO ist sowieso an
einem Schuld das ist bedenklich Unsinn
und es ist das gute Recht der
TeilnehmerInnen eine solche
Demonstration durchzuführen und für
Frieden zu demonstrieren ist
grundsätzlich sympathisch das ist aber
genauso das Recht alle anderen zu sagen
was ihr sagt ist schädlich und das ist
dann keine Zensur und das ist auch nicht
autoritär das ist der Kern unserer
Demokratie und Sie müssen sich schon die
Frage gefallen lassen worum
Bundestagsabgeordnete und
spitzenfunktionärinnen ihrer Partei
immer wieder ein massives Problem damit
haben sich vom russischen Regime zu
distanzieren
Vladimir Putin steht an der Spitze eines
gleichgeschalteten Staates der seit
Februar 2022 den Alltag seiner
Bürgerinnen und Bürger durch
meditalisiert extrem
Russland als die heilige Nacht die ihre
Heimat er hatte von Satan befreien muss
Putins Russland ist eine
menschenverachtende Diktatur und da
sollte es einer Linkspartei sich nicht
schwer fallen davon zu dist anzieren und
mit den Opfern dieser Aggression zu
solidarisieren das was aus Teilen der
Linkspartei in den letzten Monaten kommt
ist hochgradig
wir alle hier wollen Frieden und das
lieber heute als morgen aber dafür muss
man erstmal in der Lage sein klar zu
benennen wer diesen Frieden gefährdet
und das ist zweifelsohne und einzig und
allein das Regime Putins und auch
deshalb möchte ich am Ende dieser
Debatte nochmal mit ein paar Mythen
aufräumen Mythos Nummer eins die
Verhandlungsbereitschaft Russlands hat
er diese ja auch thematisiert und quasi
neben dem Antrag gleich den zweiten
Friedensplan der Linken heute
mitgeliefert und da frage ich mich
wirklich wenn man die Debatte der
letzten Monate verfolgt sieht man dass
Putins Russland kein Interesse an
Frieden hat sondern weiterhin das
einzige Ziel darin besteht den
ukrainischen Staat aufzulösen und die
Souveränität der Ukraine zu vernichten
und selbst Chinas Friedensplan von dem
wir ja auch ehrlich gesagt alle wissen
dass er am Ende auch keiner ist selbst
den hat man im Kreml abgelehnt wo sehen
Sie die Verhandlungsbereitschaft
Russlands Mythos Nummer zwei
Waffenlieferungen stoppen sorgt für
Frieden und das ist ja völliga Unsinn
das wurde ja auch schon ein paar mal
standardisiert Russland würde
weitermachen wir würden weiter
Situationen wie in Butcher und irpin
bekommen und ganz ehrlich sie fordern
die ganze Zeit Verhandlungen aber wenn
die Ukraine nicht mehr existiert weil
sie sie sich nicht mehr verteidigen kann
mit wem soll Russland dann überhaupt
noch verhandeln und Mythos Nummer drei
die Bundesregierung tut nichts anderes
als Waffen zu liefern und das ist
ehrlich gesagt einer meiner
lieblingssätze auch so sinngemäß aus
diesem Antrag und da muss ich sagen
haben sie die Regierungsarbeit der
letzten 12 Monate aber wahnsinnig
schlecht verfolgt wir sind einer der
größten Geberländer der Ukraine mit
finanziellen Mitteln mit humanitäre
Hilfe wir haben wirklich eine große Zahl
von Krieg geflüchteter Menschen aus der
Ukraine aufgenommen und ja wir liefern
auch Waffen aber das deutsche Engagement
in der Ukraine darauf
zurückzuziehen ist einfach
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Linksfraktion ich würde Sie bitten
sprechen Sie lieber mal mit den Leuten
die gemeinsam mit Rechtsaußen am
Wochenende demonstrieren gehen über
diese Mythen Stadt das Plenum mit diesem
halbgaren zwei Punkte Friedensplan zu
beschäftigen ich glaube dann werden uns
allen mehr geholfen vielen Dank
ja und Fabian Funke hat hier für die SPD
das noch mal aus seiner Sicht
zusammengefasst und einige Punkte
angesprochen die immer wieder hinter
Debatte vorkam die Linke die hatte ihre
ganze Redezeit sie hat auch in diesen
Debatten nicht so viel weil sie die
kleinste Fraktion ist also ihre ganze
Redezeit ihrem außenpolitischen Sprecher
Gregor Gysi überlassen konnte also im
weiteren Verlauf der Debatte dann nicht
mehr eingreifen der Antrag der Linken
Teile Überraschung der wird hier im
Plenum abgelehnt ja der Bundestag hat
jetzt einige andere Abstimmung noch
vorzunehmen das ganze ohne Aussprache in
ungefähr 10 Minuten geht es dann aber
weiter hier mit einer aktuellen Stunde
da wird es um die Bahnstreiks im
öffentlichen Dienst gehen dann melden
uns wieder von hier in der Zwischenzeit
informiert sie aber über weitere
aktuelle Ereignisse meine Kollegin Ines
Arland in Bonn